Cuál es el balance que ha dejado el paso
del ciclón
bueno primero esto Gracias por la
entrevista mi apellido es Julio gago
haciendo la obra bueno acá en Lima
metropolitana estamos tratando Este paso
del ciclón trabajando de la mano con el
gobierno central y el gobierno municipal
el gobierno municipal encabezado por
Rafael López aliada que es el alcalde de
Lima y en el caso de gobierno Central es
la presidenta Dina bolarte pero a través
del Ministerio de defensa porque estamos
trabajando juntamente con el ejército el
ejército hoy día está trabajando de la
mano justamente para tratar en lo
posible de evitar
de prevenir de que los problemas sean
mucho Menores en los daños sean mucho
Menores en la diferentes zonas antes que
sucedan los daños estamos explicando
mucho a la población para que se retiren
del lugar que va a ser afectado unos
como tú bien sabes no quieren retirarse
Porque viven en una laderas en la
heladera de los cerros donde tienen sus
propiedades otros están siendo evacuados
y estamos logrando de esa manera
minimizar hoy día los riesgos y los
desastres en cada lugar de Lima donde se
está presentando estaba el país y sobre
todo la capital preparados para una
calamidad como esta
Bueno realmente
yo yo en forma personal como regidor
Metropolitano te puedo decir que todavía
el IVA no estaba preparada para una
situación de esta naturaleza a pesar que
generalmente cada año cada dos años
tenemos los mismos problemas ya que son
muy parecidos a los fenómenos del niño
sin embargo se está luchando para que de
una vez lograr la prevención y también
lograr que de una vez Estas personas no
habiten en estos lugares de quebradas
que son sumamente riesgosos y que
siempre van a tener problema de la
naturaleza estamos viendo también a
dónde se van a dónde se pueden retirar a
través del gobierno central buscándoles
un lugar apropiado donde puedan vivir